and this is the fit i'm going to do a
full spin full spin damn mom
50 who
[Music]
okay so my dad just shut my phone off
can you believe it i'm 25 enough to pay
for my own phone anyways
i'm going to massage envy to get my mom
a little gift card
hi um i wanted to get something for my
mom for christmas
she says that i stress her out so i was
like
[Music]
yeah perfect place the audacity of this
man don't get me wrong he's mad right
now
because when i moved to england i may or
may not have ran out my international
bills because it took me a while to
figure out how to get a phone in england
now i have no phone so i'm going around
boneless
boneless now the other problem with not
having a cell phone is i'm a millennial
barely i'm like the youngest millennial
i grew up on gps i don't know how to get
anywhere like where am i going i know i
grew up here dad i'm sorry
i'm sorry i won't use it in england
again just turn on my phone i took a
turn um
hopefully this path leads me to home i
just want to get out oh my god there's
sauce in my face okay i had chipotle
guys i had chipotle okay sue me sue me
let's just talk about top five dumbest
things i've ever done there's literally
the gps in the car oh my god i see my
dad i'm about to confront him dad
did you turn off my phone wait my phone
just shut off i thought it was you
so it turns out
it turns out
he did not shut off my phone
what so why is it all come on verizon
today we're going to christmas mass
and this is the fit i'm going to do a
full spin damn mom
50 who
are you my mom or my sister okay then we
got amelia you look so pretty
well okay this is what you do you post a
thirst trap right and then guys will dm
you and be like hey
then you can pick
you guys had yearbook photos we have
instagram
amelia you look so pretty
this is our christmas tree and look at
that tree right there i like i want them
to look like mustard
wait dad you look so handsome
oh my god
so what were you supposed to wear
tonight
it's nice and ready that was that was
what mom
asked him to wear
eva
i love you i i love you
the feeling is done you are one of my
favorite people in the family
it would be you might even be number one
if you loved me back
[Music]
let's see there would be probably amelia
no no greg
you barely a secretary that's the point
okay and then mary and then i guess
amelia and then taz what am i last
austin
and then yeah then probably you and then
gabrielle
okay so i'm second to laugh i mean
i'll take it
oh
you look so cute
six hours
hi
all right me and gabrielle made it to
mass we're like fashionably late you
would say sorry about that that's
professional
[Music]
um i hate catholic mass it's really
boring i don't care
[Music]
fun
yeah
[Music]
if you had to pick one davis to marry
another family tradition we have is
secret santa so there's
the answer card so what we do everybody
gets assigned a secret santa and um they
have to guess whose it was and then
whoever wins gets a cash prize this
year's cash prize was 200 bucks so we
take very very seriously secret santa
you're not supposed to ask people who
they have i didn't ask i was told
i can't really open it
that's what it looks like she's 19. you
have to
it depends on the day some days it would
be adam other days it would probably be
eva in my younger in my younger days
adam and eve
probably adam is it starving enjoy a
nice beverage
sorry it's quicker than starbucks i was
like you better not see me no i honestly
i've never thought about throwing
anybody off of a building besides adam
and
eve if they're cute i'm guessing
gabrielle let me see if they're not i'm
guessing someone else
tackles the taco hell card what did i
get you he got me a massage gift did you
know why i got it for you no i don't
because you said that i stress you out
it will be well
what could it be
it's empty
[Laughter]
oh
wow did he listen to earrings he got
exactly what i asked for
[Laughter]
are they earrings and i don't know who
she has she said jazz but i was like i
lied no i love look at this
because gabrielle told or even told me
she had chat that's why i put it for eva
because i was like she acted weird when
i said that so she knows who has it and
i was like gabrielle it's not gonna work
because i ask your brother so i knew it
was eva but i still lost
today is christmas day
and i'm waiting on my siblings to get up
because
they're literally also asleep at this
many presents
and this is for
i don't want to say all ten of us
because not everyone comes to christmas
but there's like seven of us here
christmas morning my mom cooks us food
and
it's okay i guess maybe this is my
spatula
i've gained six pounds in a week from my
mom's cooking
i got what is on my face
oh wow
i'm excited i make smoothies so you
could say i carry the bulk of the family
so one of our family traditions is
making
these christmas cookies so
it was my grand great grandmother's
recipe so it's the only christmas cookie
we've ever made so it starts with dough
and then you turn them into cookies so
they're all rolled sugar cookies so
those are
little christmas trees and then we get
together with friends and we decorate
them
another christmas tradition is over here
these are my advent camp um candles so
every single day from the start of
advent they are lit the whole day all
day every day
how how did i do that okay
six pounds i've gained six pounds in a
week from my mom's cooking another
another tradition is that um
we don't ever put the tags on presents
and so everybody has to figure out what
present is there so everybody has their
own kind of wrapping paper i'm kind of
like totally into wrapping so in case
you're wondering
i make it an art form and then everybody
this is the little directory and so
the kids have to do a scavenger hunt to
figure out which um
which color is theirs and which paper is
theirs
it's so good though it's so good this
tradition started because we didn't have
a lot of money a few years and
wanted to make christmas last longer so
we tortured them so is that the answers
i have it on video i say get you a girl
that cooks right
wrong you're gonna get fat
fat oh and another tradition
that's over here is there is an ornament
that has
everybody's names on it and it's it says
2021 but there's so many heads you can't
even see what it is anymore
um and this year we have morgan she's
new
so and we'd really like melissa right in
there but austin hasn't really figured
out how to
put a ring on it so these are our
christmas stockings
that's another tradition
another tradition we have are these
nutcrackers so for 2021 these are the
nutcrackers that everybody got and i
always try to find a nutcracker that
kind of represents them so
this is hannah's and she's in england
right now and okay this is probably more
scottish than english but that kind of
looks
sort of like europe
[Applause]
this food which is ready
to kill it out here
[Music]
if you walk over here you can see
all of the different nutcrackers from
all the years so
when we only had two kids there was just
two nutcrackers so three kids this is
with adam
four this is gabrielle
and then five this must be eva so every
year as we added kids uh they added
nutcracker so that's that whole
collection up there so
now that austin and melissa have their
own house we're thinking that our
collection's going to start dissipating
because they're going to go home with
them
[Music]
another family tradition is these
pajamas and every year
everybody gets christmas jeans and they
can't open their presents from santa
until they put them on so we've got
somebody one of the boys this is the
boys this year
and they just got white long sleeve
t-shirts which we thought were kind of
cool
so another family tradition is this
advent calendar that one of our former
au pairs had made for us and this year
we got to bring it back out because we
have new neighbor kids and so we got to
do fun things and put little treasures
in there for them so that was a fun one
do you miss me not really what'd you get
you're not going to see me for like
eight months after this
wow
i'm gonna miss you so much
i love you
guys
look at the wall
i love you
curse my
one of these is going to be a car
i don't think so they're still trying to
fix barbara i got airpods i was excited
i was really excited for my headset
because i used to use wired headphones
for my computer and my cats kept eating
them so they kept breaking so i've been
using a speaker for the past like two
months but it's annoying because i don't
like people listening to my
conversations so now i do like
eavesdropping yeah that's rude yeah
or something i am telling you something
actually completely
you don't like dad's clothes well he had
some really nice pants and then i see
him like pouring concrete at him and i'm
like
that's
what's the best gift dad has ever gotten
you
um my heart necklace did dad pick those
up
dad what's the best gift mom has ever
gotten you oh definitely jeans
[Music]
no no what's the best gift i just said
it jeans oh yeah
okay
hey what do you think is the best gift
you've gotten dad uh his hot chocolate
machine
yeah okay
when did do you use it it broke yourself
you